it's Shazam the fury of the Gods a
fun-filled follow-up or just a muddy
mess early reviews are in here's what DC
fans should expect
the soon to be retold DC Universe is
attracting a fair amount of attention
these days with fans wondering what
direction James Gunn and Peter saffron
will take the struggling brand but they
want to compete directly with the MCU
and offer light-hearted fare for the
whole family or would they double down
on the dark and gritty as it had done
previously or perhaps would they finally
figure out how to successfully mix both
as such all eyes are on the upcoming
Shazam Fury of the Gods movie which is a
direct sequel to Shazam while the film
alongside the flash was created before
the decision to rework the DCU saffron
is a producer and the film could be a
sign of what's in store for DC's future
the original 2019 movie was praised for
its tone and for its General sense of
fun and someone that if the sequel would
be able to capture this lightning in a
bottle once again now that some early
reactions are in for Shazam Fury of the
Gods it looks like DC may have a rare
hiss on their hands which certainly is a
promising sign for what is succumb
critics and others who have been given
the privilege of seeing Shazam Fury of
the Gods early I've already started to
Heap Praise on the movie via Twitter
John Wynn of nerd reactor posted Shazam
Fury of the Gods is a fun-filled
adventure that's a solid follow-up to
the first film there is plenty of humor
action and heart and it's always a treat
to see the family together again I wish
the movie was longer since there are a
lot of characters Cinema Blends Eric
Eisenberg also felt the same way and
wrote that Fury of the Gods is a super
fun and worthy sequel to the original
film he added that although the Shazam
sequel isn't a movie that will forever
change comic book movies it is still a
great film filled with energy and
exceptionally likable characters Shabazz
from the movie podcast could barely
contain his feelings about the movie
claiming that it is the most fun he's
ever had at the movie theater and
specifically praise the performances of
Helen Mirren Lucy Liu and Rachel zegler
as well as the efforts of director David
F Sandberg the daughters of Atlas are
coming to hunt us
Jamie broadnecks of black girl nerds was
another big fan posting Shazam continues
to lean into his silliness and
immaturity in this sequel which sells us
as franchise will remain to keep these
films funny lights and slapstick-ish the
sequel comes with more action compelling
villains and a complicated anti-hero
Brandon Davis of comicbook.com was also
pleased with the movie writing it's a
really good sequel the theme of found
family delivers great emotional beats
Sandberg sprinkles some horror elements
while maintaining the childish joy and
charm of the shazamoli nothing brand new
but highly entertaining really enjoyed
it varieties Courtney Howard said that
the sequel packs the punch adding that
it delivers on all fronts MTV's Tyrell
Charles was a little more critical in
his review and said that even though
Shazam 2 is entertaining it is very much
a standard issue superhero film with a
third act that drags on a little bit
digital spice Gabriella Geisinger
probably had the spiciest opinion so far
by saying that Fury of the Gods only has
a few bright spots and that the third
Act is a muddy Mass however most early
reviewers have thoroughly enjoyed Shazam
too so it will be interesting to see how
General audiences react to this latest
suffering from DC
[Music]